It's time for another-
*maniacal coughing*
Skrattar du så förlorar du, mannen.
*intro*
Yes, yes, yes, another one
*slow clap*
How many more?
How many more is he gonna make?
Ah geez...
I sure hope no one calls me out on it, for milking a series, cuz that has never been done before
*Outrageous slam*
Looking at you, Mr. Happy Wheels.
Now, let's have a little bit of (Felix laughs), okay. Is that too much to ask?
Last week I asked you to send in some videos
I'm not gonna do that because they were goddamn awful.
[Video narrator] So the first stop is a cranberry capital of the world: Warrens, Wisconsin.
It was amazing seeing these vast fields of cranberries this close, so I decided to take a closer look-
[Felix] Alright, this is really- really funny
[video] Take some on my own
[Felix] He's gonna fall in
haha
ha ha ha ha
ho ho ho ho
I didn't- I didn't see that one coming,
OH MY GOD that's hilarious! [vid] A closer look and get some on my own-
*cranberry gurgles*
OHHHHHHH
my god, these are FUNNY.
[video] There's a story behind my skin,
It's a mosaic of all the faces before it.
I'm English, Irish, German, and Cherokee.
I'm a hundred percent-
*SCREECH PAUSE, EXHALE OF RELIEF*
I never pressed the pause button so fast in my life. Oh my God.
*EXHALE OF RELIEF #2*
I'm sweating.
*under breath* oh that was a close one. Christian channel.
Christian channel... this-
*EXHALE OF RELIEF #3*
[vid] The third circle tonight. We talked about this the first two-
[woman] SAY NO!
[man] You need to learn to say "no".
Je-Jesse, if you take this turn-
If you take this- if you-
Je- JESSE! *Japanese driving hype music*
[Felix] Yes!
*Japanese driving hype music*
[man] STOP IT!
JESSE NO!
*Japanese driving hype music*
You are so grounded!
[Felix] What a gangster,
You can't tell Jesse to do NOTHING.
He is so grounded.
[man] You are so grounded!
[Felix] YOU'RE SO GROUNDED! *chuckles*
Why do you let him drive then? What the heck man.
*inhale* ahh
Ah, I've seen this
It's so good
*chuckle*
His face and he's just like, "Oh, you got me! YOU GOT ME MAYNN YOU GOT ME-
HAHA!
Ahh... bootiful.
[vid] Who are safer drivers, men or women? Well, according to a new survey
55% of adults feel that women are most responsible for minor fender benders,
while 78% blame men for most fatal crashes.
please note that the percentages in these pie graphs do not add up to 100%
because the math was done by a woman
*mixed reaction from audience and Pewds*
[Felix] Buh, bu- HHH!
to those of you hissing at that joke, it should be noted that that joke was written by A WOMAN. So...
Now you don't know what the hell to do
*laughter from audience*
Nah, I'm just kidding. We don't hire women.
*louder laughter from crowd, silent laugh from Felix*
*stops*
[Felix] Moving on, moving on.
Thank you so much for masturbating over my stream and donating two thousand dollars you virgin! Let me go ahead and write you down on the board right here.
[man] WOW, can you guys show him some love
Woww can you guys show Steven some love on the board right here wow
[Felix] *chuckles* good old Steven
[man] so much $$, oh my gawd Steven, ah my white board
okay
I really don't understand why I keep getting hate in the community
everybody just comes in here saying I do this for the money
No I don't i do it cuz I love it ❤︎
Wow that wasn't
NO Felix Christian Channel *whispers* stop laughing
all right what do we got, what do we got, what do we got, OHH?
*chuckles*
maybe I need a friend for Slippy, maybe that's his problem, hey, Slippy what do you think of this?
you know what i'm amazed that he hasn't taking a shit yet so
so I'm not gonn-i'm not gonna gamble
okay
why did I think that it's a good idea to get a god damn toadd
so moist you know, it's kinda nice for your-
HELP
what the fuck
what are you doing, what- don't touch it, who told you to touch it, I'll fucking kill you, don't ever touch that fucking shit again
where is that from, *HUHHH* wait it's a song
oh, hell yeah it made me *AH HA HA* but I still haven't lost, ok, what do we got?
god damn it's so hard to be a Christian Channel these day
people don't understand, PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND, you can't kill a bull with an apple
idiots THESE MORONS
okay, okay
[video narrating] a more practiced framing carpenter can set a nail with three hits
wait sorry, what the heck is "memes from Estonia", what is that, wha- and an experienced carpenter can sink one with two hits
but only an alpha knows how to drive a nail with a single hit
uh-huh, okay, yeah how you gonna do dat
oh god
OH
family friendly Memes from Estonia I approve of you thank you very much Estonia for your keep- for Keeping it Family Friendly
Thank you Estonia you know, usually when you go to the eastern sides and people start looking like this
Its- it's and it's never good it's weird explosions, drugs, guns
Okay a family friendly memes from Estonia, very nice, very nice family friendly Memes from Estonia, I really appreciate it. thank you
okay, I see where this is going and I'm going to choose to stop there but thank you
it could be family friendly
Holy Moly
*chuckles* look at his face, it's so red *laughs*
what's the context here please someone fill me in, fill me in what is happening here, where is he?
Holy Moly, thank you for not swearing, thank you for keeping it real Holy moly is is
is a family-friendly statement Holy Moly indeed as you guys can see
Luke he Kill me with the stun stun he can't use a stun yeah Guys Look
What yeah yeah Look Guys Look Look?
Hey Disconnected Yeah Guys
Thanks for Watching Guys
This Guy
It's the next damn Pewdiepie
my god what a talent, *OH MY GAWD* very nice
varry no-
is that a chicken, let's get it
it's always the quick ones that get me man I don't even know
what is this, oh?
oh sizzles, oh
ey ey ey can't censor that
WOW
*OH MAH GAWD*
yeah go in for the attack dude look at that sneaky he's floating over
look, he misses the broom
a crucial miss, you can't miss from that distance the coon is gonna get you
the broom is dead at this point and then I assume
what happens here is that he dies as well from the coon?
you don- you don't mess with a coon man
look at him, he just floats in, out of no where
he just floats in out of no where
how does he do that?
ahh, i don't know what to tell you man
Nicolas , this train is gonna crash into these five people
should we move the train to go this way?
or should we let the train it go that way, which way should-
wow that's really interesting teaching a child?
moral dilemmas at an- at an early age
this child, it's a brilliant mind, it's a genius, my god OF COURSE
literally the answer, no one is ever given to this dilemma
hahh
dat is right little Timmy, if we move over the lady, she can get Killed as well, is a genius
clearly he's just respecting women here and there's nothing else to it
WELL, what do you KNOW, did you laugh or did you lose?
why do I always say that, you know what
Heck it i'm going with it
Hope you enjoyed the video ahh- remember to buy my chair
everyone, I sell Shairs
Shairs
see you next week with another one
and remember kids: stay family friendly, christian
who am i, anymore at all
BROFIST
for the good old tames
let's give 'em the-
let's give 'em what they want
let's give 'em what they want, they want a BROFIST I know you want a brofist
there it is- there it is
classic 2012, come on man, nothing's bad gonna happen, I promise
you know what, give it a little kiss
give it a little kiss
you kiss it too you, kiss it too
LICK IT